on a un réel enjeu aujourd'hui de casser
la circulation du virus qui est déjà
très très active sur ce territoire du
fesc de comme vous pouvez le constater
de ses 54 cas positifs
on était sur la plage on mangeait une
gaufre de tout d'un coup
les gendarmes sont arrivés nous ont
interpellés nous ont dit que 21h que
c'était fermé c'était interdit de
qu'on est parti
on fait quand même des belles journées
je crois que les gens sont quand même
rassuré le fait que tout le monde il
masque de bonnes mesures ont été mises
en place et le fait qu'on a et aux sites
où se faire dépister ça va permettre de
bien enrayée aussi là le virus donc je
pense que toute façon il se développe
partout le virus à cuba qui vont donc du
coup je pense que les gens maintenant
size apprendre à vivre avec et je pense
que les gens vont quand même venir
surpris par les circonstances et ce qui
se passe subissant un peu malgré tout on
essaye de faire tester pour pouvoir
revenir chez nous et pouvoir travailler
en toute circonstance pour moi avoir
peut-être même une attestation à donner
à notre employeur
là nous tout à l'heure on rentre on va
rentrer sur paris donc il faut voir
comment la situation sera là bas mais
seulement qui est pas plus que ça à part
le fait qu' on doit se balader avec des
masques désagréments mineurs